I'm actually just kind of curious about
the process of how something is greatly
produced as this comes together so
quickly it's like how soon after the
news came out did the idea of this show
get conceived who made the first call
and can you kind of like walk us through
what those first initial steps were -
yeah yes you know this is really my team
there's I have an amazing I mean you
know I can have an idea but I I have the
people here that you see I've been with
some of these people for 25 years we can
speak to each other without even
speaking we can communicate in shorthand
and so this was Trump made those
comments on Thursday night Friday all of
us were just processing the comments
Saturday I'm at dinner with my wife was
at the table and I said why aren't I
going to Haiti and my wife looked at me
and she said go to Haiti or go to hell
things are falling apart quickly no she
said yeah Haiti
I stood up walked outside the restaurant
and sent a email to Jeff Ross and Jeff
Ross said sounds good to me and I said
okay I
we go we have to go now because people's
feelings are hurt right now this isn't
one of those stay tuned for Cohen's
reaction to what the president said this
summer this has to happen now we all
agreed to meet at my house on Sunday so
we met on Sunday morning we sat around
the table and already by then Jeff and
Mike Sweeney and Jason Shelley me who's
a rock star
they'd already figured out oh and
Anderson Cooper should get a shout out
because I sent a note to Anderson and I
said you spoke so passionately about
Haiti and I know that you go there do
you have any connections and I said we
need to move quickly before the
president does something else like you
know physically assaults a deer on the
White House lawn and and he and we got
to go a man and he wrote right back and
said okay you know I've got the person
you should talk to who's on the ground
in Haiti and so we started we made that
decision and then announced it
immediately on Sunday and then already
we had called our talent department and
they had said okay we can double tape we
got the celebrities
to agree to not shoot on Thursday but to
all come on Wednesday we shot two shows
on Wednesday jumped on a plane flew
there and went in pretty lean landed
Thursday morning slept for about an hour
and a half and then got up and and went
out and that's when you see me run into
those people who are all yelling and so
I'm just still trying to process hey you
know I had this noble idea and you get
in there and everyone's mad at me but I
love that part of the show because that
was you know go towards people that are
mad at you and talk to them and say why
are you
what's do I understand why you're first
of all I understand why you're angry you
have every right to be angry
what's that prepared for the potential
tension no I wasn't why I didn't know
what I was gonna run into I wasn't
prepared for people being that angry the
first day when we were just getting
started but that turned out to be one of
my favorite parts of the whole show
that's the other thing about doing these
kinds of shows is that the thing that
most people would tell you oh we got to
edit that out because that looked a
little unpleasant and they looked angry
that's usually going to be the best part
of the show because it's it's reality
[Applause]
you